To this demo video of how to install Cognotic desktop
on Windows. Simply go to cognotic.com. And
download the installer file or you can go to GitHub
Under releases and see all of the installer artifacts. I'm
going to click on download for Windows. Save this file
Because it isn't commonly downloaded, you may have to manually
keep the file. Before you open it to install
install it like any install it like any desktop. And
there we go. Next, we need to configure the application
We go to Cognotic in the Start menu. Run it
now. This is a server-based application, so when you run
Cognotic from the Start menu, this is starting the server
You have to go to the taskbar, click the server
icon for Cognotic, and that will open a browser page
From there you need a login. This is a system
local login that's used to secure your API credentials, so
If you don't have one already, you can easily register
for this. I'm just going to say fubar. And for
password, I'll say test. Weak passwords in my for
Space, it won't allow space. When you register. It
will launch a confirmation dialogue which unfortunately sometimes doesn't come
up. On the top, so you have to find it
with Alt tab. This is to prevent people over the
internet, uh, for example, potentially creating and using your
service. You say yes. And
now we have access. We need to go to settings
to add our API key. We have provider It
supports a number of different providers, but I mainly use
and therefore mainly recommend Anthropic and Gemini. Caterins
Don't save that. And the password manager, you need to
re refresh the page first. Test the basic chat, and
we see haiku, haikuanthropic. That means the models were discovered
It probably works, but let's do the full test. Hi
All right, now we have Cognotic fully installed, configured, and
tested, and we are ready to run one of the
applications.